que ce soit du brusc monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
il y a trait à très exactement 20 ans
l'organisation des nations unies et son
secrétaire général ont reçu le prix
nobel de la paix à l'occasion de la
cérémonie de remise des prix l'ex
secrétaire général kofi annan a dit nous
sommes entrés dans le troisième
millénaire par une barrière de feu
malheureusement il semble que nous
n'ayons toujours pas pu éteindre ce feu
depuis des désirs des dizaines d'années
nous connaissons une période de
turbulences et d'imprévisibilité
mondiale inédite c'est la conséquence
est que ce logique du fait que notre
planète fonctionne en grande partie hors
du carcan du système des obligations
consacré comme principe universel du
droit international par la charte
aujourd'hui le monde 2 est régi par
l'écho isme économique les ambitions
politiques le chantage les habitudes
impérialistes les crises les conflits et
le chaos orchestré les tentatives
incessantes de certains états d'imposer
à deux états souverains un modèle de
développement socio économique la
politique barbare des sanctions à
l'encontre d'états considérés comme
indésirables le terrorisme économique et
le retour à des oppositions de blocs
sont tant de facteurs qui n'ont que peu
de choses à voir avec un ordre mondial
équitable et harmonieux auquel nous
aspirons depuis des décennies c'est le
signe clair d'un désigne d'un désir
obsessionnel et maladif à attiser les
foyers de confrontation dans le monde
l'ingérence ouverte d'acteurs politiques
se proclamant oracle dans les affaires
intérieures d'états souverains et la
norme aujourd'hui de la coexistence
internationale des états les dynamiques
négatives dans le domaine de la sécurité
internationales augmentent
inexorablement en particulier en raison
de guerre hybride l'utilisation
malveillante et criminel dtic qui
nourrissent mme l'extrémisme et le
terrorisme et les informations
mensongères aujourd'hui des gadgets
électroniques peuvent saper la paix et
l'harmonie intérieure d'un pays et
écarté du pouvoir ces autorités
en outre le monde est pris en otages
depuis plus d'un an et demi par la
pandémie de lakovic 19 elle a coûté des
millions de vies entraîné des pertes
socio économiques irréversible et a
provoqué nombre
de processus mondiaux délétère nous
appuyons pleinement le processus en
cours à l'om est-ce visant à renforcer
l'organisation pour réagir aux
situations d'urgence dans le domaine de
la santé nous notons en outre qu'il est
absolument nécessaire de refuser tout
poli politisation de ce thème et
d'étudier les causes de la pandémie ces
dernières années le bélarus a
continué d'appeler l'attention de la
communauté internationale sur la
nécessité de lancer un nouveau dialogue
mondial sur la sécurité cette question
et plus qu'opportune ce format de
communication est appelée à résoudre le
principal enjeu créer un nouvel ordre
international
fonctionnant bien et qu'ils soient
réellement équitable nous appelons les
grandes puissances a entamé ce dialogue
à reconnaître leur responsabilité pour
l'avenir de la planète et à réaliser la
mission civilisationnel dont ils sont à
la tête il est également importante
d'envisager la composante économique de
ce nouvel ordre mondial malheureusement
la mondialisation économique ne sert pas
les intérêts de tous
nous voyons qu'il existe un grand
potentiel dans les processus régionaux
d'intégration pour l'économie mondiale
nous appelons cette approche
l'intégration de l'intégration en mai le
bélarus en partenariat avec la barbade
et la cnuced a organisé une réunion
virtuelle de haut niveau sur
l'utilisation de l'intégration inter
régionale aux fins de la réalisation des
eaux d'aider les dirigeants des grandes
organisations économiques régionales ont
chaleureusement appuyé l'idée de
renforcer la coopération interrégionale
2021 est une année importante dans
l'histoire du bélarus et des états
frères puisqu'il s'agit du 80e
anniversaire du début de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
les méfaits des nazis ont entraîné la
mort de millions de personnes dans le
monde lors des années les plus sombres
de la guerre un tiers de la population a
perdu la vie dans la lutte contre les
oppresseurs lnah 10 et leurs
collaborateurs qui ont commis un
génocide contre notre peuple à notre
grand regret nous voyons aujourd'hui des
tendances dangereuses à donner une
analyse des formes et du point de vue
moral et juridique de la deuxième guerre
mondiale à mettre sur un pied d'égalité
les droits des victimes et des bourreaux
des libérateurs et des agresseurs et à
remettre en doute les décisions du
tribunal de new york nous sommes
décidément opposé à toute tentative de
blanchir les nazis et de justifier leurs
crimes innommables c'est pour cette
raison que le bélarus a adopté une
nouvelle loi prévoyant des poursuites
pénales pour la réhabilitation du
nazisme et des poursuites pénales ont
également été lancés
eu égard au génocide du peuple du
bélarus lors de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en tant que pays fondateurs de
l'onu le bélarus portera cette question
dans l'arène internationale afin de
rappeler les principes fondateurs de
notre organisation
d'ailleurs certains criminels des
criminels qui ont commis des méfaits
contre le peuple du bélarus et qui ont
du sang sur les mains vivent encore
aujourd'hui tranquillement dans certains
pays voisins il dit sont même vénéré
comme des héros
malgré les appels lancés chaque année
dans cette salle a renforcé la sécurité
le multilatéralisme la solidarité et
l'aide mutuelle le monde ne connaît
aujourd'hui un degré des plus élevées de
confrontation le bélarus a également été
poussé contre sa volonté dans l'abyme
d'une guerre géopolitique
voilà plus d'un an que notre pays est la
cible d'une pression agressifs de la
part de l'occident et tout cela car le
scénario attentivement préparé d'une
nouvelle révolution de couleur au
bélarus a été un échec une révolution
qui correspondait aux élections
présidentielles aujourd'hui le bélarus
est victime d'une guerre hybride de
grande envergure dans tous les domaines
nous sommes étonnés par l'inventivité
des hauteurs de qualificatifs certes
beau mais hypocrite qui visent à
justifier leurs actes destructeurs ils
parlent de mesures d' aide à la
démocratie de restriction sectorielle
ou encore d'assistance au bien être de
la population et à la souveraineté de
l'état toutefois la nature de ces
mesures est clair
l'occident ne peut accepter le choix de
la majeure partie des habitants du
bélarus 4 le choix des électeurs du
bélarus ce nuit aux plans de certains
stratèges l'offensive éclair à
l'encontre des autorités du bélarus a
été un échec et l'occident a rapidement
perdu les rues malgré les manifestations
organisées de l'extérieur leurs calculs
ont échoué le blé russe continue de
suivre la voie qu'il a choisie librement
aujourd'hui le peuple du bélarus est
unie sur le cap stratégique visant à
créer un état fort souverain est
florissant c'est ce qui est appelé à
faire la réforme constitutionnelle
inclusive mise en place au belarus et à
laquelle participent tous les groupes du
pays
en outre afin de continuer à démoniser
le bélarus le présenter comme une source
de tension dans la région et justifier
ses actes destructeurs à l'encontre de
notre état l'occident a fabriqué de
toutes pièces une situation de conflit
impliquant des réfugiés à la frontière
occidentale de notre pays oubliant ses
obligations vis-à-vis de notre pays et
des pays d'origine des réfugiés
aujourd'hui des millions de réfugiés
veulent se rendre dans l'europe
abondante afin de se préserver de la
faim et des catastrophes créé par
l'europe et l'occident dans telle ou
telle région
mais ils ont trouvé porte close en
europe même dans les pays voisins du
bélarus la pologne les états baltes par
exemple les réfugiés ne sont pas
seulement passée à tabac mais ils sont
tués et leurs corps sans vie sont
ensuite transportés en secret la nuit et
au travers de la frontière avec le
bélarus ce n'est pas là un cas isolé
c'est la norme du comportement de nos
voisins occidentaux
ne s'agit-il pas là du comble du cynisme
et du blasphème de la part des apôtres
des droits de l'homme qui considèrent
qu'ils ont atteint le plus haut niveau
de la civilisation et tente de donner à
d'autres des leçons sur la manière de
ivre la question des réfugiés est devenu
d'autant plus actuel mais cette fois en
raison de la politique est responsable
de l'occident l'afghanistan en est une
preuve claire il ne faut pas dans ce
contexte tenté d'accuser autrui de ses
propres mots et d'accuser le bélarus de
mener une guerre hybride e contre
l'union européenne
comme l'on dit de manière mensongère à
cette tribune les dirigeants de la
pologne de la lituanie de la lettonie et
d'autres pays
le quidam peut le comprendre la
bélarusse 6 et 10 millions d'habitants
n'est pas en mesure de mener une guerre
hybride mais n'est même pas et n'est pas
en mesure de mener une guerre contre
l'union européenne et ses 500 millions
d'habitants même si elle avait les
muscles d'arnold schwarzenegger depuis
avril nous proposons à l'union
européenne de mener des consultations
sur les migrations illégales mais nos
propositions fait lettre morte en outre
en violation des accords conclus
précédemment
l'union européenne a interrompu le
financement de tous les projets
concernant la migration illégale
si on réponse aux propositions de
dialogue la réponse et la construction
d'un rideau de fer fait de barbelés la
faute en revient à ceux qui sèment le
malheur nous sommes toujours nous serons
toujours favorable à une politique de
bon voisinage
fondée sur la maxime nos voisins sont un
don de dieu le bélarus sera toujours
attaché une coopération mutuellement
profitable avec tous les états même avec
ceux avec qui nous entretenons des
différents nous construirons toutefois
nos relations sur la base du principe du
respect d'égalité sans chantage et très
conditions le bélarus a toujours été à
l'avant-garde des efforts visant à
lutter contre la traite tant au niveau
national qu'international
le bélarus portera la troisième
commission
avec un large éventail de pays a animés
du même esprit la résolution habituel
intitulé amélioration de la coordination
des efforts pour lutter contre la traite
cette résolution est un élément
fondamental des efforts internationaux
visant à assurer la stabilité dans le
monde nous appelons les états se porter
coauteur de cette résolution et a appuyé
son adoption nous nous félicitons de la
tenue en novembre d'une réunion de haut
niveau consacrée à la lutte contre la
traite à l'onu mesdames et messieurs
nous devons pas oublier un autre thème
un thème qui fait déjà grincer des dents
en raison des spéculations qui
l'entourent la question des droits de
l'homme il semble pourtant qu'il s'agit
d'une question positif pour tous mais
aujourd'hui la question des droits de
l'homme est non seulement un jouet
dangereux aux mains de certains
politiciens maladroit et peu clairvoyant
c'est également devenu une réelle arme
contre des pays indocile et considérés
comme indésirables la démocratie découpé
selon les gabarits de l'occident ne
coïncident pas la situation de
différents pays mais elle cause même
le chaos et l'instabilité
j'ai déjà mentionné l'afghanistan c'est
un exemple clair d'une politique
déraisonnable de la part des chantres de
la démocratie mais c'est l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale qui emporte
les conséquences même à démocrates helle
que le président français macron à il y
à un mois reconnu qu'il était impossible
d'imposer la démocratie de l'extérieur
notamment par la force
les tentatives de certains pays
développés comme on les appelle de
monopoliser les droits d'auteur sur la
démocratie de définir de manière
arbitraire le degré de démocratisation
d'un pays et en fonction de cela de
coller des étiquettes blessantes sur des
états souverains rappelle clairement les
méthodes des nazis qui établissait un
distinguo entre ce qui était appelé à
régner et ceux qui étaient appelés à
être des esclaves
une autre pratique favorite des états
occidentaux
consiste dans des mesures unilatérales
restrictive alors qu'ils ne comprennent
pas la situation dans tel ou tel pays
des politiciens y résonne
irresponsable par manque d'imagination
immédiatement recours à l'épée affûté
des sanctions si quelque chose ne leur
plaît pas le danger de cette politique
est claire le recours aux sanctions nuit
viole de manière flagrante le droit
international et nuit de manière
irréversible au système des relations
internationales en accroissant le
potentiel de conflit et l'hostilité sur
la scène internationale le bélarus est
solidaire avec tous les pays qui
subissent les sanctions nous soutenons
le peuple frère de cuba qui
connaît un blocus économique injuste
depuis tant d'années en raison du bon
vouloir d'un état il est clair que les
principales victimes de ces sanctions
sont les simples citoyens les
restrictions sur le commerce le secteur
bancaire le secteur des transports et
sur les devises ont des conséquences
négatives sur le bien-être de la
population sur l'initiative privée cela
nuit aux possibilités d'enseignement et
cela crée des risques d'insécurité
alimentaire les sanctions sectorielle
unilatérale le contre des grands
exportateurs de matières premières
utilisées dans le domaine agricole y
compris les engrais au potassium créer
non seulement un déficit de cette
précieuse denrée sur les marchés
mondiaux et entraîne une hausse
exponentielle des prix mais cela cause
également
[Musique]
des mots pour les simples citoyens dans
des pays vulnérables en particulier en
afrique en asie et dans bien des régions
du monde il suffit de prendre pour
exemple les interventions de nombre de
représentants ici présents à l'assemblée
près d'un milliard de personnes
souffrent aujourd'hui de la faim et ce
en raison du manque de clairvoyance
d'une poignée d'états qui appliquent eux
des sanctions économiques ont des pans
entiers de l'économie liée à
l'agriculture et des centaines de
millions de personnes chris que encore
de souffrir de la famine
l'utilisation de sanctions financières
et économiques de manière arbitraire en
tant qu'instrument de pression politique
doit être à jamais du passé et cela doit
également faire partie des compétences
de l'onu monsieur le président l'onu est
appelée à jouer un rô le fondamental
pour résoudre tous les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
toutefois nous sommes préoccupés du fait
que l'onuci revient souvent de théâtre
pour certains états plutôt que de servir
de plateforme
d'acteurs commun
l'onu est de plus en plus commercialisés
et ses programmes se transforme en
politique occidentale l'onu pense de
plus en plus comme l'occident se et
foulent du pied les principes de
solidarité et de multilatéralisme alors
que l'onu vise à ne laisser personne
pour contre le bélarus se considèrent
qu'il est impératif de se fonder sur le
consensus et sur le point de vue de tous
les états je souhaite également mettre
en exergue une autre tendance
inquiétante nous
voyons que certains tentent soi-disant
d'améliorer l'efficacité des travaux de
l'assemblée générale
mais il se cache là en réalité des
tentatives
d'interpréter de manière arbitraire
la répartition des travaux est de revoir
cette répartition des travaux les
travaux visant à promouvoir la société
civile assemblée générale ne sont pas
exception il s'agit là d'une tentative
de donner aux ong qui sont bien souvent
fondés à l'étranger le un statut
semblable à celui d'état membre
souverain de l'onu c'est tout à fait
inacceptable
je souhaite rappeler un principe
fondamental de l'onu un état une voix
nous sommes opposés à toute tentative
visant à diluer le statut souverains des
états membres de l'onu a créé des
marionnettes sous la forme des ong qui
pourront faire taire des états
indépendants
inondé de manière incontrôlable le
système des nations unies des ong ne
permettra pas d'entendre leur voix mais
cela compliquerait également le consent
le consensus un consensus qu'il est de
plus en plus difficile d'année en année
de trouver à l'assemblée générale la
participation de la société civile aux
travaux de l'onu doit se faire
conformément aux procédures existantes
monsieur le président dans un de ses
discours martin luther king a fait
preuve d'une grande sagesse est une
sagesse dont nous avons besoin ensemble
apprenons à vivre ensemble ou nous
mourrons comme des fous
aujourd'hui le monde a besoin plus que
jamais de solidarité des mutuelles et
d'efforts collectifs afin de surmonter
tous les différends afin ne pas mourir
comme des fous et ne pas pousser le
monde dans le chaos d'une autre guerre
qui serait la dernière de l'histoire de
l'humanité nous appelons tous les états
à faire preuve de cette même sagesse la
sagesse et le courage de mettre de côté
ses ambitions afin de donner vie aux
espoirs qui nous aide était confiée il
ya 76 ans par les représentants de la
conférence de san francisco a créé un
système de relations internationales
stable et prévisible je vous remercie
arrêtez je vous remercie les ministres
des affaires étrangères du bélarus de
son intervention